Amanda starts off this hour in Seattle
Washington hey Amanda how are you hello
I'm hanging in there it's an honor to
talk to you today thing to do for your
time sure how can I help
unfortunately my husband suddenly passed
away last month oh you sound young how
old was he um he was only 47 and I'm 40
and we have five children one of them's
in college but I have four minor
children at home luckily we were
prepared and we were like what happened
um he had a heart attack Oh Lord I'm so
sorry thank you
oh I thought it was a month ago yeah
just a little over a month ago
and I thought I made a lot of big
decisions those first few weeks but I'm
realizing I have a lot of big decisions
to make in the future yeah I guess and
how old are the five the four kids at
home uh 10 12 15 and 17 how they doing
um they're doing okay um comes and goes
it comes and goes
exactly you got family in your area
they're to be around you're good Church
family or anything yes absolutely we
feel the love and support of so many
we're very blessed good okay so now
you're facing these big decisions and
they keep getting bigger right and so
I've gone to see a few financial
advisors and I'm surprised that all of
them say don't pay off your house which
is opposite of what you say and so I
don't know I just wanted to kind of give
you the homework shot how much life
insurance did you get um we're going to
get about nine hundred and seventy one
thousand much do you own your home 265
thousand and I'm guessing you're
full-time at home um I work part-time I
work like about 12 hours a week is there
other any other investments other than
this million dollars no that's it yep
okay um you got a lot of baby chicks to
feed uh-huh and it's scary and sad that
everything they're facing and it's
overwhelming okay first thing I try to
do in these situations is I try to not
make decisions for a while okay and get
where you can breathe big decisions that
you have to do okay I mean you've got to
pay the light bill you got to go buy
groceries you got to pay the house
payment you know that kind of stuff but
you don't need to go selling a car
buying a car selling a house paying off
a house deciding on a bunch of
investments you have understand while
these waves of grief crash in because
you have moments of sanity and moments
where you can't breathe unless you're
not human
no it's very true exactly what you're
describing yeah and so just give
yourself a little room it'll always hurt
but everyday it'll hurt a little less
and every week and every month it'll
it'll you know you'll get your head I'll
just clear up and so it usually takes
most people that are saying about a year
for their brain to start fully working
after what y'all been through okay and
so I would I'm not sure we can in this
situation but I would try to not make
any major decisions for about a year
from his passing okay and that just
gives I just gives you takes the
pressure off you know you don't have to
have an MBA in finance to argue with
some goober financial professional you
just put some money in the bank you know
just put it in a CD they're just boring
and just sit there and and cry it's okay
and just give yourself some time now
I'll talk to you about the other stuff
of after your head gets cleared up but
to the extent you can do that that's
what I would do and I think by a large
extent you can do that okay now you may
have some little things that you're just
a hundred percent sure I don't want his
car sit in the driveway okay that's cool
you got rid of that you know that's fine
it's not the end of the world it's
unless it was some kind of a classic car
that you want to keep for your sons or
something like that then you might have
acted emotionally you don't want to get
rid of it
so but I mean if it's just any old car
sitting there and you want get rid of it
that's fine you know you only but one
you know little stuff that's a little
thing but do you have any debt other
than your home it's well I'd charge the
whole funeral just to my credit card
because it was easy at the time so
you'll clear that up yeah it's really I
mean it's like $15,000 I mean you know
like the other side of this pause hit
pause suggestion is you do need to jump
on every dollar and you do need to start
your budget because that'll give you
some account of bed and if you have
somebody loves you enough to look at it
with you and will call you on your stuff
I don't want you doing grief spending is
the other side sure because I have a
friend his wife died or I mean I had a
friend he died his wife went through
$239,000 and four months oh my goodness
and he had never made over 40 grand in
his life in a year and so but she just
went crazy you know and that's okay
sometimes people do I'm not mad at her
but you got a you got to put some checks
and balances to keep you from doing
anything and so you have somebody look
at your budget over your shoulder you
know if you got a friend or a family
member that's that's not trying to be
controlling or toxic that just says no
darling I wouldn't do that right now you
need to you need to back off on this a
little bit know the kids don't you can't
you know don't spend a bunch of grief
spending on the kids oh he'll feel
Johnny he'll feel better if he has a
$500,000 skateboard no he won't
oh my brother has been going with me to
all these appointments and we've
actually looked at my budget I've been
keeping it spreadsheet and please looked
at it and I'm very grateful for my
brother so I don't feel like I'm going
to go crazy I do it I don't think you
are either
I'm just telling you checks and balances
one side we don't want to make big
decisions until we let our brain clear
two is we're saying our brains not clear
because we're human and so we want
somebody else to look at the budget just
so you don't edge over into some kind of
grief spending of some kind cuz I want
all this money there next year when you
get ready to do something cuz you're
gonna need every bit of that
sure okay so that's all I'm saying
so every dollar calm and get your budget
upload it's real easy to do with your
iPhone or Android or on
computer real easy and you can let your
brother have access to your account he
can watch with you okay very easy to do
it's free have you ever been through
Financial Peace University I have not I
want you to go through as my guest oh
thank you okay and I want you to meet
with one of our financial coaches that
has been trained by us as a Howard guest
no charge that would be fantastic
there's one right there in Seattle and
our financial coaches do not sell
anything they're not in the investment
business okay and all of that just to
help you do nothing for a little while
okay okay and just breathe and just feel
a hug coming from us okay thank you I
appreciate that very much
now then next spring you know I'm
probably going to pay off your house if
I'm you and because of the and I'm
probably looking for some different
financial advisors by next spring you
may want to meet with one of our
endorsed local providers for investing
that we recommend and they would be
investment guys and gals that would
recommend you pay off your house and
they'll help you invest the rest of it
for the good of your family but you need
to be debt-free now I'm a Christian and
the Bible tells me to take care of
widows and I'm trying to right now so
you hold on and Kelly will pick up and
we're going to put a bunch of people
around you no charge and make sure
you're cared for kiddo this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you